Phegley filmmakers are continually
trying to represent humanistic images
through design that means that when they
create a scene with colors textures and
lighting they hope that scene can be
faithfully recreated onto film or
digital capturing the key ingredient to
that recreation is the camera lens the
Lycus summilux see lenses deliver
excited right is that close some lucky
lenses deliver ultra high optical
performance just can't occur me all
night for a second that I have all the
hard things to say I'm my husband I'm
the beauty here I'm the eye candy and
the brain hello that's slow in come on
am i right the first boat I've ever worn
what's this little unfair and the like a
similar Lux see lenses deliver I'll try
optical performance with film and
digital cameras they incorporate noble
teleson a series ok they incorporate
novel telecentric multi-element a
spherical optics and this full series of
Frank thank you
and this full Syria I'm done yet full
series of prime lenses delivers
unprecedented optical and mechanical
performance what she said on the
mechanical side precision machining
gives each focus ring and iris ring
after C and E's of repeatability for the
operator the small size of the lenses
means smaller camera packages cases and
rigs on the optical side the aspherical
elements in each lens create a
telecentric path of light allowing more
illumination across the entire field ok
the beauty of these lenses was most
recently seen in Birdman gone girl and
whitley oh my god I loved that man I
love ya I was such a good fountain what
did you say that I loved it yeah did you
see with the Academy presents the
scientific and engineering award to Ian
Neil for designing the optics and to
andre de winter for designing the
precision mechanics in the entire range
of Micah's not alike feelings
okay all that telecentric stuffing she's
okay so on behalf of dr. andreas Kaufman
honor of CW sonder optic and chairman of
the supervisory board of like a camera
and Audrey deventer and myself I'd like
to thank the academy for this award of
course the lens project was a team
effort and firstly I thank Kristian
screen and all tournaments for the
concept and original specification of
the lenses some other people involved in
the lens project we'd like to thank for
their contributions are Eric five
clinger Gerhard buyer Reiner Schnabel
Julie Schroeder Bill McGrath and rollin
Albert I apologized the many others
involved in the project we did not
mention but all of their efforts are
appreciated I can't forget mentioning my
family for their support throughout the
project lastly my mom couldn't make it
the awards this time unfortunately but I
hope that she's looking down from above
Andre
well there's gold in them thar hills
well I like to thank my wife and kids
also my daughter Linda who traveled from
thule to yesterday to see her father in
a penguin suit and i think yeah I think
oh also hey thanks again from both of us
and thanks again
you